so we've just ran an event freedom
formula intensive
and some of the guys upgraded onto the e
academy which is all of our training
programs
and you know what when people register
for the e-academy i like to call them up
and just say congratulations
dude i've got your address in dagenham
i'll tell you what you you don't have
you don't have another deal
i'm literally i have every good reason
to come knock you out bro
so i've been calling some people up made
about 20 calls today
yeah i know you know you're scared and
you're hanging up and stuff but
not sure what happened
but some of the guys didn't answer so
i'm gonna drive to their houses right
now
and just gift them personally the
e-academy starter pack
and congratulate them for going on the
course so let's go to the house
and surprise them samuel leads property
millionaire and
postman today
it's just i don't understand the things
that change is so quick it's just
i don't know you're so real like
anything you say even lit every every
advice it seems cliche i will say to
them sometimes
some of you guys i heard the things you
told me or didn't want to listen say no
guess what i wouldn't do this and i'll
do my way and then i guess when i apply
the things you guys said they really
work
yeah yeah yeah you have to go right i'm
so glad and honestly
you know you've been selling deals and
getting some success
so i just thought i had to swing by i
didn't get hold of you so i thought i'm
going to go to london
drop off your e-academy parcel and then
i'll go home
you got alistair's book
whatever
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you for being a customer and we're
believing in you all the way so
i think i really want to be one of the
ladies because i i
like when i saw the evictions like only
oh no
can they complain sometimes i come from
a really
male world like in south of italy that's
why i love them that there was more
opportunities because the ladies they
just
you know they stay home and if you're
ambitious again like you said
but you know what next time next time i
see you
instead of it being at your house it'll
probably be at my house for a windows on
a wednesday
so you'll see my target because uh my
little nieces they were saying this
something i think was because of them
they're like the little kids here
they were saying about they want to do
charity and things that was telling what
you do
and then all the others like oh just
shut up like you know
it's like yeah you get the job you said
you know it's not like this they can do
more there are other things they can do
because i have to cook for them i have
to show them because like you say
when you say but when you proof it then
they start to
listen to your investment and then the
money the cash flow you go
yeah and then you gave me some literally
one little bigger devices
i said oh these deals how do i sell them
and you
you told me go on these groups don't
just go groups of property go
groups like put names like millionaire
money finance
and just people everyone has got money
and i talk to them do network don't be
outselling
everything you said i know when i say to
other people younger students
i invested just a few thousand i don't
know what people think is so expensive
and making this money i mean while we
were on the crash course i keep
receiving thousands of bank accounts
i went to the cash point and printed the
receipt
just to to look at myself i put it in my
car
uh the receipt of the bank bank balance
i said
one week ago it was much lower how is
possible that's amazing i think this
screenshot is possible just growing up
every day like
amazing yeah let's go it's fair enough
some you know so you sold four deals
i didn't mean candy because it's like
this one when you asked very much and
honestly
one was two thousand and hundred one two
five nine
one two thousand and the other one
actually i got an investor now
um the big development in london so that
is a
fifteen thousand and i give a part
because i need to support this too many
phone calls i'm
maybe overwhelmed one that's why today
was greater formula
i need to structure now it's okay the
beginning you just do do it
yeah so you're gonna be a year so keep
up the good work thank you for your
if you're all positive energy all the
time and uh yeah i'll see you around
oh don't worry don't worry i'm gonna
have my dinner this is my house he was
very small but i was uh really really
like bad
bad so i was hoping to find a way to
refinance because the money from yeah
this year thank you so much
[Applause]
all right i'll see you real soon
[Music]
see you real soon thank you thank you
bye guys
love you guys thank you amanda
okay everyone
well i think she was happy well i think
she was happy to see
guys i'm shaking i cannot tell you i
don't have
a lot to say i can't breathe
i'm okay i'm okay i just
i had a surprise visit at my house
i'm just keep crying and shaking
oh my goodness
oh my god okay
it all starts at the crash course yes
it's true
it's true to all the trolls you all
started the crash course
this is real my life and my best
friend's life is changing
from here to here to here to here 20
[Music]
times
[Music]
[Music]
hello
oh hi samuel i'm fine thank you for the
call
you're so welcome i'm actually i'm
actually just calling to say
congratulations for
registering on to the e academy
oh no you're so welcome um are you are
you excited about the
about the journey very very excited um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
about you guys and they've got a parcel
for you and stuff as well so
i'm on the phone she has no idea i'm
here
that must have been a husband or
something
what are you talking about i'm speaking
to him on the phone i think you were in
actually because i pressed the buzzer a
few minutes ago
yeah so i thought i'll just phone the
reference there so i um
i tried to phone you with that go get
through it forget it i'm gonna come
around my house
[Music]
it's lovely to meet you
yeah it was a great day today it was
fabulous it was just like really really
exciting with all these sort of like
tips i'm looking forward to really sort
of getting
thinking you're gonna love it yeah well
in there it's just a little something
you've got some books and things like
that in there
but you'll get all your manuals and
contracts taking the post yeah and
um yeah thank you
welcome back
so that's it you order from me you
become a customer of mine
i might just turn up at your house who
knows
[Music]
you